Prof: This is one
family's experience,
and, as Qing said,
it's quite different for
different people,
but what you should realize is
that this is one of 300 million
such stories.
The stories may be different
but there's 300 million of them.
That's what the Chinese
government is now saying,
that the one child policy has
averted 300 million births in
China.
Their population,
instead of being 1.3 billion
now, would be 1.6 billion.
300 million people is the total
population of the United States.
China has, as they perceive it,
as they claim,
averted putting another United
States worth of population into
the world.
That's the significance of
spending two full lectures on
China,
and we could of course spend a
lot more,
is that China is just so big
that everything that happens
there has these tremendous
significances,
both on an individual personal
level for each individual or
family that experiences it,
but also on the global level.
One out of every five human
beings lives in China,
so it is very big.
We'll talk in a later lecture
explicitly about the one-child
policy, but there's information
I have to give you today to
understand what it's about.
Let me just say,
now, that the Chinese
government is of course well
aware of the human and human
rights sacrifices of the
individual people,
but they argue that the
benefits outweigh the suffering.
Just to give you a little hint
of the way the government thinks
about it,
and many other people in China,
that the great economic boom
that China has had--
most economists now around the
world attribute the kick off of
that to the reduction in
fertility,
that they didn't have to cope
with so many children and that's
the cause of their economy
taking off.
They perceive that the
one-child policy has allowed
China to emerge from this
grinding poverty that they were
in and become a modern--
at least start to become a
modern nation in the world.
Another story--another data set
that I just recently came across
was--had to do with carbon
emissions.
At a world average of carbon
usage,
which is probably below what
China is actually using,
300 extra million people would
have produced 1.5 billion,
that's billion with a
"b,"
tons of CO_2 each
year and that's more than the
total CO_2 production
of an industrial giant like
Germany.
If you're looking at this issue
from an environmental point of
view,
the reduction of people and
their environmental impact
makes,
again, a huge difference.
The Chinese,
for instance,
feel that because of the
one-child policy alone,
they have done more than any
other country to ameliorate the
environmental crisis.
That's just a hint of the very
difficult things--
how do you weigh the story of a
family and 300 million families
like you just heard against
these sort of macro issues.
It is not easy.
The question I want to set up
today, which is to go backwards,
is this kind of policy happens
only in China.
This kind of enormous
population, as the Chinese
perceive it, overpopulation,
happens in China really and in
India in terms of massive stuff.
We've talked a little about
India and South Asia.
The question is,
what's special about China?
Why did this happen in China?
Why did, as they perceive it,
population get so out of
control that the government felt
that they had to introduce such
a Draconian policy as this,
such a stringent kind of policy.
The flip side of that coin is,
why is China just now digging
out from the abject poverty that
the people were in when Europe
and America dug out 200 years
ago?
I mean England started it,
but all of Europe and America
went through this phase 200
years ago, and why not China?
Of course this is a very,
very hotly contested issue
among historians.
The basic set up of the story
is that in about 1800,
when Malthus was writing,
China was very powerful,
very strong,
a very rich country and the
West was beginning to be that
way.
The industrial revolution was
just starting in England,
and you would have seen
enormous differences between
China and say England or Europe
in 1800,
but you would not have been
able to predict which model was
going to take over the world,
which country was going to
become bigger and stronger in
the future.
China was a very impressive
place in 1800 and Europe was
beginning to be a very
impressive place in 1800.
Then I may go into a little bit
the history a little bit more.
By 1840, when the British
invaded with the opium war,
the British started to addict
the Chinese to opium and the
Chinese government said,
No.
The British cried free trade
and invaded to force China to
accept British opium,
which they got out of India.
That's a separate story which
we may or may not have time for.
Then in a very short period of
time China goes from being one
of the dominant countries in the
world to being sort of the pawn
in the world that the British
start colonizing it,
the Germans start colonizing
it, the Americans take
advantage,
everybody starts taking
advantage of China,
the colonization of China
starts the dismembering of
China.
Why did this happen is one of
the major issues in world
history.
There's many,
many different points of view
on this, there's ten major
theories or something.
In this class,
I just have time to unwind one
thread--
one version of the story and
only one thread of that story
and that's the relationship
between the population of China,
the wealth of China,
and the poverty of China.
This particular thread about
population was obvious to
Europeans visiting China,
even in the European Middle
Ages.
Marco Polo visited China in the
1200s,
and he described China's
cultivation,
how every little bit of land
was under very intense
cultivation already,
populousness,
that the population was already
incredibly dense as viewed
through European eyes of the
same time.
And industry,
the people worked very hard and
whatever they did they were very
productive at it.
The stories of Kublai Khan and
all that were from Marco Polo
that he sort of idolized China
as this incredibly rich but
very, very crowded place.
Adam Smith, in the seventeenth
century,
the guy who started modern
economics,
said "China has long been
one of the richest,
most fertile,
best cultivated,
and most industrious and most
populous countries in the
world" so Adam Smith was
aware of it.
All of these great scholars of
the late 1700s were looking
around the world finally.
There was enough seafaring;
they could go around the world
and compare different things,
and try to figure out what was
the best system for people to
live under.
A few years after Adam Smith,
Malthus writes and he quotes
the information that Europeans
were getting were mostly from
Jesuit priests who had gone over
to China to try to convert the
population.
He quotes one rather well known
Jesuit priest then,
China is "The richest and
most flourishing empire in the
world," but the priest goes
on,
but, because of overpopulation,
the people are 'the poorest and
most miserable of all.'"
Right from way,
way back, people are aware that
China was basically a very rich
country,
but because of the huge
population,
the individual families were
often in abject poverty.
While if you looked at the
emperor and the nobles,
of course, they had enormous
wealth.
These early observers were
certainly correct about the
population issue there.
We have data from,
say 1750, and China had 500
people per cultivated square
kilometer.
At the same time Europe had
about 70 people per the square
kilometer,
so China had to,
on the same farmland,
had to support seven times as
many people.
Of course, the numbers are from
1750, so don't take them as any
kind of exact numbers.
Up to today,
China has something like 20% of
the world's population.
Because of the one child
policy, the ratio was higher,
they had more than 20% but now
it's down to about 20% because
India is still coming up.
A lot of the world is still
coming up and China,
the population is still
increasing but increasing at a
rather slow rate.
It has now 20% of the world's
population but only 6% to 7% of
the arable land,
the farmable land in the world.
The amount of farmland per
person is 0.2 acres per person,
ten times less than the United
States has.
There's a real problem with
China's population and the
question is why did China's
population press up against
their resources and riches of
the land so much more so than in
say Europe?
For most of history,
China's population does not
look terribly different--
you can see this,
that in the Han Dynasty,
which was the first unifying
dynasty of China,
very much the same time as the
Roman Empire.
It had a population of 50 or 60
million,
then according to this
reconstruction of China's
history,
and all these reconstructions
are very iffy,
you notice the population stays
stable for 1000 years.
Then, during the Song Dynasty,
which is one of the very most
important dynasties in China,
very successful,
population rises and then it
falls back down again.
Yuan, which are the Mongol
invasions, this decline is
probably very much characterized
by the Mongol invasions.
The particular dates here are
dates when we have censuses,
when the various emperors took
censuses,
and in between we really don't
know what's happening,
and you're also not sure how
complete these censuses are.
Anyway, the Mongol invasion.
Then it stays constant,
and then sometime in this
period,
probably there's no census
really, they don't have any data
between 1400 and 1750 so this
curve in here is guesswork,
but sometime in the 1700s,
as in Europe,
the population takes off.
Something like this doesn't
look wildly, in shape,
in magnitude it's different,
but in shape it doesn't look
very different than Europe.
In the Han Dynasty 60 million
Chinese--
1,400 years later in 1393 they
counted 60.5 million people and
in between the population went
as low as 37 million.
Then as I said the Mongol
invasions decimated the
population and then just--
before the European Black Death
but decimation the same sense as
the European Black Death and
then it took a long time for
China's population to come back
up.
By the beginning of the Ming
Dynasty,
one of the also very
flourishing periods in Chinese
history,
China had maybe 75 million
people, up from 60 million.
Then it starts doubling,
in the next 200 years it
doubles and continues on up.
As in Europe there were major
epidemics.
In the 1640s there was some
major epidemic that we can liken
to plague, but people really
don't know what kind of disease
it was.
A Chinese scholar wrote in
1642, "The
pestilence,"
we don't know what,
"The pestilence arose
again on a large scale affecting
eight or nine of every ten
households.
In a household of ten or 20
people all would be afflicted
and often all would die.
At first the bodies were buried
in coffins and next in grasses,
but finally they were just left
in the places where they
died."
In one big city in 1643 there
were few--
there was basically no signs of
human life in the streets,
"only the buzzing of flies
broke the silence."
Those are quotes from Chinese
observers.
Very interestingly,
it was at this time in the
1640s that the Chinese,
having experienced this massive
disease,
developed a new medical theory
of disease and epidemics based
on Chi,
and you've all heard of Chi,
which is supposedly sort of the
life force that's involved in
acupuncture and everything.
Their view was that there was
this sort of non-material
substance,
force, kind of like phlogiston
in the West and it had to be in
balance,
and when the Chi on heaven and
earth,
there was Chi in heaven and Chi
on earth,
got disrupted then plague--then
chaos broke out on earth and
people started dying of various
diseases.
Of course you know Americans
have recently become wildly
infatuated with Chinese medicine
and the Chi theory of things and
acupuncture,
and we can talk a lot about
that privately if you wish but
the point is it did not help the
Chinese at all.
You can see the birth--the
medical statistics,
again as far as we have them,
and up until recent times from
the practice of acupuncture you
don't see any form of disease
lessened at all and the only
thing you see in China,
and Japan also,
is a tremendous rise in
hepatitis because of the
transmission from the needles
because they didn't understand
anything about sterilization.
Then these plagues caused
enormous political changes just
as in Europe.
The Ming Dynasty,
for instance,
fell,
possibly as a result of the
depopulation and chaos of the
plague and that allowed the
Mongol's to come in and set up
their own dynasty.
I'm sorry the Manchu from
Manchuria, the Manchu to come in
and set up the Qing Dynasty.
Similarly to Europe,
after one of these decimations
of the population,
good land became available and
people moved into the good land
and they had a blossoming of
wealth and culture even for the
peasants.
It's a cycle not very different
than what Malthus talked about,
balancing the relationship
between the number of people and
the amount of land available.
Throughout this whole period,
life expectancy was very poor.
We have scattered statistics,
so a village in the 1790s
showed that one-third of male
children died in their first
year of life and half of them
died before they were 20,
and the female situation was
comparable but probably worse
because of infanticide,
so they're probably counting
only those that got through the
period of infanticide.
Life expectancy was 32 in this
particular village and only 4%
of the population lived past 65.
Again, it's not terribly
different than what we saw in
the statistic--
the graph for CisAlpine Gall,
where about a third of the
women are dead before they start
their reproductive life.
When the Ming came to power
there was still land--unoccupied
land available.
As Malthus said,
the best land was already used
for agriculture but there was
less good land still available.
Under the Ming the population
grew, we're talking 1600s into
1700s, the Ming--I'm sorry that
ends in 1650 or so.
The population grew,
what did the people do?
They moved onto the marginal
land and that meant higher into
the mountains on steeper--trying
to farm on steeper slopes.
They cleared forested areas,
they moved into dry areas,
and the result of all this was
enormous soil erosion,
especially on the mountainsides
in the dry areas.
The productivity dropped
because this land is just not
good and the erosion--the forest
couldn't hold the water anymore.
The period of China--China's
always had floods,
it's a big part of the Chinese
history,
but these really massive,
massive uncontrollable floods
date from this period where the
people--
the population increased and
people started going into areas
where it's ecologically very
unstable,
cutting down the forests and
then when it rains you get these
enormous floods.
The floods not only--they
devastated the agriculture in
the lowlands so you not only had
a poorer agriculture per capita
in the highlands,
but you also reduced the per
capita farming in the lowlands.
Again, population growth can
make it difficult for everybody.
Again, like Europe and like
Africa,
American foods,
when they were discovered,
went into China because they,
as I said,
have something like twice the
caloric content of anything
except rice.
If you can grow rice,
rice is as good as potatoes or
just about as good.
China picked up sweet potatoes
especially, peanuts especially,
some white potatoes,
and they doubled food
production.
Guess what happened?
The population doubled,
so again, the introduction of
these foods and the tremendous
improvement in agriculture
didn't help the per capita
eating,
the per capita amount of food
for individuals.
During this same period,
as people increased,
one farmer could grow more
food, but the people that could
eat needed more land for
themselves,
so they moved farther out and
the land under cultivation
increased by a factor of 4.5
times.
But, again, during this sort of
second round of population
growth,
one is--when the Ming take over
and one is after American foods
are introduced,
the erosion becomes extreme.
It's so extreme that,
by 1978, about one-third of all
arable land in China had to be
abandoned because of erosion.
So, it's an enormous problem in
China.
This is really--China
experienced Malthus,
what I call Malthus with a
vengeance,
so this is the cultivated land
and you can see that here 1700
or so basically American foods
come in and you can plant stuff
everywhere,
and the amount of land under
cultivation goes up like crazy.
Some of this decline is very
recent, is industrialization,
cities growing,
and some of it is erosion.
The land thing looks like an
enormous increase in the amount
of land available for farming
but here is the per capita
amount of land,
the cultivated land hectares
per capita,
where this is simple hectares
and it grows,
then it crashes,
probably again to do with the
Mongol invasions so just fewer
people.
I'm sorry I've got this
backwards,
it rises here the land per
capita because you just get rid
of the people and then,
in the modern population
growth, the land per capita just
crashes down.
Now it's--this is 0.2 hectares
now were 0.1 hectare per person,
which is like a quarter of an
acre, a very small amount of
land per person.
Of course the Chinese realized
this, as well as anybody,
and it was a matter of official
concern during the Ming and the
Qing dynasties.
In 1790, just before Malthus
wrote,
a Chinese scholar and high
government official,
Hong Liang-ji,
he started warning the Chinese
about the difficulties that
unchecked population would cause
as it outraced Chinese
productive capacity,
that's the way he phrased it.
It's clear that the original
understanding of China,
that its population was
pressing really severely against
its resources,
was accurate but it still
doesn't explain why was it in
China that you got these
incredibly dense populations.
Why didn't that happen
elsewhere say in China or
England?
What jumps to your mind?
Probably a very high fertility,
they had no--in England we
talked about the late marriage
system and everything which kept
fertility down.
Americans generally have the
image and Westerners generally
have the image that the Chinese
reproduce--have a lot of
children all the time;
it's like your grandparents or
something.
This makes good sense in the
Chinese culture.
The principal goal of life was
to produce sons,
as you've heard over and over
again,
and this origin of ancestor
worship I think as you just
said,
goes back at least to the
second and third millennia B.C.,
so 5000 years,
what Qing said is the scholarly
number.
They did all kinds of things to
get a son,
adoption was very,
very common,
you'll read about that in the
reading if you haven't already,
James Lee talks about very high
rates of adoption,
people who didn't have a son
would get an adoption.
The filial piety that they had,
a Confucian system,
which I'll talk about in a
moment, where the older--
the younger brothers for
instance had to pay absolute
obedience to the older brothers
and they all had to pay absolute
obedience to the father.
If a younger brother had a son
and the older brother didn't,
the younger brother had to give
that son to the older brother.
By modern times that was the
same situation in Qing's family,
of course that Confucian,
that strict Confucian thing
doesn't exist anymore,
but in the old days it would
always be the younger son's no
matter what the biological story
was it would always be the
younger sons that did not have
male children.
In China, everyone was expected
to marry,
and they married very young in
order to secure a bride because,
as I mentioned to you,
I think with respect to the sex
selective abortion,
traditionally China has always
done away with 10% to 25% of its
females,
so there was always--not always
but as much as we have data,
and so there's always been an
excess of males and a lot of--
they can't get married so they
did all kinds of things to
secure a bride for a son and
that included getting betrothed
very,
very young and starting
reproduction as puberty allowed.
It was made worse by the fact
that it was quite acceptable for
males to take second wives,
or third wives,
or fourth wives down into
concubines and every time one
male had more than one wife then
some other male got no wife at
all.
Let's look--so one of the
possibilities is the obvious
one, is China had very high
fertility, and we'll see if
that's true.
Here's a bunch of data,
and what this is,
is the age of the woman and
they don't have much
reproduction beyond age 40 in
this sample,
although modernly we would have;
the age of the woman and what
her rate is per--I guess per
1000 women.
You can see--women start out at
age 20 with a very high rate and
all these curves with a high
rate of reproduction.
It either goes down a little
bit by age 25 or in some places
increases a little bit by age
25,
and then as the woman gets
older fertility drops off,
there's fewer and fewer
children per year.
Forty year olds just have fewer
children then 20 or 25 year
olds, that's a very obvious kind
of thing.
Now these are two different
sets of population and this is
data from one area of the world,
data from another area of the
world.
One area is all the data from
China with one line from Japan
and the other set of data is
Europe, and various European
countries.
Guess which is which?
Some hands;
a big difference in fertility.
Student:  Is China the
one on the bottom?
Prof: You think China's
the one at the bottom.
Student:  One of the
articles they're talking about
how a lot--
like some of these families
actually have low fertility
because of marital restraint.
Prof: That's right,
that's the Lee article.
We're one lecture behind as
you've probably realized
already, and so the reading that
you should do tonight actually
gave away the answer.
Yes, this is the European
population, this is the Chinese
population.
The Chinese,
once married,
within marriage,
and in both places extramarital
fertility is not a big deal so
this is--
you can take this as general
reproduction but within marriage
the Europeans had a much higher
rate of childbearing then the
Chinese did.
In fact, it's almost a factor
of two, from 200 to 300,
from 400 to 500 that it was a
lot.
The Europeans,
once married once having access
to sex really had children
uncontrollably as one says,
whereas, the Chinese were doing
something to control their
births.
That was a shocker when this
data came out,
it's fairly recent data,
because the presumption,
from at least Malthus' time,
was that the Chinese just
reproduced like flies or
something and that the Europeans
had this wonderful restraint and
it turns out that's just the
opposite of what it is true.
It's very surprising given the
cultural emphasis on
reproduction by the Chinese.
One of the big issues now under
discussion is whether this is a
sign whether the Chinese were
consciously doing some kind of
birth control,
they were consciously trying to
limit their families,
or whether it was one of these
cultural things where the
culture in some sense stumbles
onto a practice and it makes
that culture successful,
even though the people have no
idea what the purpose of it is.
It may just be sort of an
artifact of culture and they
will think,
the population will think this
is due to their following God's
rules or proper decorum,
or various cultural reasons,
they will give you cultural
reasons why they have few
children,
and not understand that that's
what makes the whole society
survive.
James Lee, who is definitely
the world's foremost demographer
of China,
he has no doubt,
even though the data's not as
solid as one would like,
he has no doubt that it was
infrequent sexual activity that
led to the low birthrate,
as a cultural thing not as a
conscious way of reducing
fertility.
He describes a story where a
young couple gets married and
they're in the--
what we perceive as the height
of sexual desire and--
but their sleeping arrangements
are they have--
there's a double-decker bed and
they're married--
the young married couple sleeps
above and the grandmother is in
the bed below,
and the grandmother--carries
her cane to bed and whenever
upstairs she hears things
starting to go on bang,
bang, bang, cut it out and so
that kind of thing that the old
people didn't go along with
this.
The reason for this,
as the Chinese would see it,
is that the Confucian ethic,
they don't have--
it's not a religious thing at
all, there's no sense of a deity
or anything supernatural going
on,
but personal relationships are
what's important.
They are a set of unequal
personal relationship;
a subject has to give absolute
deference to the ruler,
the emperor.
Children have to give absolute
deference to the parents and to
elders.
Women have to give absolute
deference first to her brothers
and then to her husband,
women to men.
Younger brothers have to give
absolute deference to their
older brothers.
Of these, the only relationship
that's equal is friend/friend
relationship,
that's the fifth relationship,
so you can be buddies with your
friend but you must be superior
to your wife,
and your wife must be inferior
to you,
and so you cannot be friends
with them.
Love or passion between a
married couple not only didn't
happen,
it was not approved of,
it was like being--
you're being bad if you love
your wife,
if you have passion for your
wife, that was not a good thing.
Husband and wife did not relate
to each other as lovers or even
as friends.
And there's a very famous
Chinese story where a young man
had been married some years,
is walking with a friend--with
another male friend with whom he
can befriend and converse and
he's bemoaning his fate that
here,
he loves his wife so extremely
but he can't have a--
he can't express his love for
her to her,
he can't have walks in the
moonlight like he's having with
his male friend,
he can't have this kind of a
chat with her because that is
against the morality and ethics
of the system.
These cultural things,
which I think no Chinese of the
time would describe as 'that's
the way we keep our population
down,' is what's the explanation
for this,
rather than some kind of
conscious effort.
Another factor that is not a
conscious sort of thing is the
Chinese married younger then
Europeans.
When you do an age adjusted
thing, by 20 they had been
married for several years,
and there's what called the
boredom factor going on,
that no matter what age couples
marry at they have sex a lot in
the beginning and so--
if they're not protecting
themselves they have a high
birthrate and then it falls
down.
Some fraction of this
difference here may just be due
to the age of marriage.
Student:  So then why is
that Chinese population is so
much more dense?
Prof: Yeah,
we're going to get to that.
Actually we may not get to it
until next time but that's
still,
again we're pushing--we still
haven't explained why the
population is more dense--
it's getting time--let me just
finish saying something about
this 10% to 25% getting rid of
the females,
which again,
would reduce the population
would lead you to not think
there was such a density.
In the seventeenth century,
again this is from Jesuit
missionaries to China,
reporting back to Europe,
they were horrified to find
that in Beijing along,
Peking at the time,
several thousand babies,
almost exclusively females,
were thrown into the streets
like refuse to be collected each
morning by carriers who dumped
them into huge pits outside the
city.
It sounds very much like Europe
of the similar time.
What's interesting is that,
right now,
China is approaching pretty
much the same female,
with the sex selective
infanticide,
pretty the same female deficit
that's been as far as we can
tell a traditional level of it,
but now there's all this
moaning and groaning about all
these unmarried males and how it
will utterly disrupt Chinese
society and it's a horrible sort
of thing.
Also, I think I mentioned this
before,
as you've seen in Europe rather
than 10% to 25% of the males not
being able to get married
because of the deficit of
females,
40%, 50%, and 60% of the males
did not get married in Europe.
I showed you the graphs of that
when we discussed Europe.
The Chinese system,
fertility system,
which keeps their population
manageable,
not small but manageable,
is moderately early,
not extremely early,
moderately early and nearly
universal marriage of surviving
females.
In 1998, for instance,
only 1% of Chinese women were
unmarried by age 30,
whereas, in the west in that
year 15% were unmarried 15 times
as much,
even by age 40 in the west.
The European system was that
only about half of everybody got
married,
but once married they had
births at about twice the rate
of Chinese and Chinese all the
women got married,
but within marriage they had a
low rate of fertility.
You have to--you cut your
fertility down by half either by
the European thing of less than
complete marriage or by the
Chinese thing of less than
complete fertility.
It looks like that fertility,
the total fertility rates
should be more or less the same
between China and Europe,
but by essentially opposite
kinds of fertility systems.
We'll see--I'm sorry next time
we'll continue and we'll see
what is one of the theories for
why China got into the
difficulties,
it was not just uncontrolled
reproduction.